I hope I'll just be going and everyone
will be like damn what happened to her
and I'll be like I've been gweatest so
actress Gwyneth Paltrow has a lifestyle
website called goop hmm that suggests
usually very expensive things to do to
make your life better
expensive better so basically I've
created a day based off of Gwyneth
Paltrow's blogs and interviews and
recipe books how I think she lives her
day and I'm going to try to emulate that
so I'm leaving you today as Chelsea but
tomorrow I'm gonna be Gwyneth it's gonna
be great about to get on the train to go
to the exercise class that Gweneth
Paltrow does just got the class it felt
a little voltage no one said anything
and everyone just like knew what to do
it was weird
I had a good time I'm very tired in the
morning when it gives her children a
little spoonful of flaxseed oil I'm
giving my child a little bit of coconut
oil I'm about to make bread and smoothie
I have chosen action dust
I'm sitting on the floor so I can lay
out my makeup and chant over it to put
positive energy in it because that is
something that is advised by goop and
gwennyth many dogs in the back I tend to
my dog house and they're gonna come back
read some emails do some work cook
yourself some lunch and then go to my
cupping appointment
hopefully won't hurt just I've been
tapping I have intense bruising
I've been up since 6:00 a.m. I am NOT a
morning person but I'm have so much
energy I don't know if it's the maca
powder in the smoothie
maybe it's the cupping I'm a little
tired and I still have to work out for
one more hour make dinner drink a
martini and take a bath Oh God cigarette
even though I don't smoke God my drink
I'm in my bath wearing a face mask is
tingling and I'm exhausted I kind of
can't wait to just be myself again so
basically I did a bunch of glamorous
things expensive things all day and I
don't feel any more glamorous I think
that the whole idea of these glamorous
lifestyles and blogging about it is that
you don't see the other aspect of
everyone's life like getting to those
appointments smelling the garbage on the
street while you're going there and all
of those other things and so it's it's
not a good idea to hold yourself up to
those standards
but I do like cupping I don't know if
I'll do it again but it was cool
ooh I don't keep doing you I'm gonna
keep doing me and that's cuz that's all
we can do